hi everybody I'm Jimmy and this is
bright insight so today I want to talk
with you about the unfinished obelisk
located in the Aswan quarry in Egypt
more than 137 feet long and it finished
would have weighed at least twelve
hundred tons it would have been the
world's largest obelisk by far now you
may be familiar with other obelisks most
notably the Washington Monument located
in Washington DC however unlike the
Washington Monument this obelisk is
carved out of solid bedrock particularly
rose granite with a high concentration
of quartz which puts it at a seven out
of ten on the most scale of hardness
thus debunking what Martin Egyptologists
claim where the tools utilized in order
to carve this stone for example dolerite
stone hammers in bronze chisels are what
modern Egyptologists claim were utilized
in order to carve this solid piece of
bedrock into an obelisk however a
significant amount of modern stone
masons have claimed it well that's just
not possible and that it would
essentially be like trying to cut in
carve wood with another piece of wood
just doesn't work like that so the
question becomes if the right stone
hammers and bronze chisels were not
utilized to construct this project that
what would have been done when you look
at these photos here you can clearly see
some sort of scoop marks with some sort
of technology that we're not familiar
with however it's very important to
understand that this is solid bedrock
rose granite and that was ever utilized
had to have either been steel or some
sort of sound resonating technology that
we're just not familiar with today
in fact I highly recommend that you
check out Bryan foresters YouTube
channel or his web site hidden ingot
Orascom where many of these photos do
originate from however I did source all
these photos from Google Images now he
has demonstrated that if they were
utilizing bronze chisels and stone
hammers they couldn't possibly have made
these types of incisions on the
underbelly of this stone obelisk and in
fact you can clearly see in these photos
that the angle would not have allowed
anyone to make these type of cuts with
those type of tools and despite the fact
that those tools weren't strong enough
to do it in the first place ie the
bronze chisels clearly some other
explanation is required now the argument
of how they cut this is one thing ensure
yes it's possible that over time with
enough people found
stone hammers could have done some of
this I suppose I think it's incredibly
unlikely but this moved past the stone
cutting part and discussed how they
would have moved it now one of the
largest obelisks that was once in Luxor
Egypt is now at the Vatican however to
move into the 1930s they had to take it
apart into multiple pieces only to
reconstruct it later now what's
interesting about this is that its
original piece wait at least 455 tons
which having been moved from the Aswan
quarry to Luxor Egypt is more than 252
kilometers or 156 miles so the question
becomes how did they move something so
massive
Kayson points in 2012 the Los Angeles
Museum of the Arts moved to 340 ton
stone in order to be located at the
Museum now this stone was moved over a
hundred miles and it took 11 nights but
to do so they had to custom order an
emirate international truck that was 295
feet long
196 wheels in more than 27 feet wide and
they had to use a million different
alternate routes because no overpasses
or bridges could sustain the incredible
amount of weight for this 340 ton stone
now this 1200 ton obelisk although was
it completed and moved is three and a
half times that weight so when you
consider the fact that one of these
obelisk was moved from the Aswan quarry
to Luxor Egypt 156 miles away how did
they do that look guys I don't have all
the answers on how they did this but
what I can tell you is what modern
textbooks are still teaching in schools
today is clearly inaccurate in that
there's far more to the story than what
we were taught in school
what's all that being said I highly
recommend you research what modern
Mason's are saying how they demonstrated
first hand the bronze chisels couldn't
possibly have cut this type of stone and
that dolerite stone hammers I mean you
have to pound it for hours and hours
just to create a few crumbs it's pretty
ridiculous so with that being said check
out some of the research out there
that's being conducted by Bryan Forester
and many many others anyways guys I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight leave a
comment let me know what your thoughts
are and like and subscribe and help me
spread the message take care everybody